[Music]
single and ready to mingle
is that your status is that what's
happening totally guys seem like you're
still good friends yeah Kevin and I are
really good friends we will continue to
be in each other's life in some regard
and he just like the best guy the
sweetest guy who just wants like shower
girl with like love and affection and
like emotional protection and like real
protection like all the good stuff that
you want a husband just not that
connection there where I thought it was
my husband you know a lot of fans out
there are really hoping for a
reconciliation with Jared oh yeah what
do you have to say about that Oh time
will only tell right are you open to
that sure he is right there he's here
what does he make of the break-up he's
trying to say it out of it what's next
for you well I'm working out promoting a
show that is coming out week to week
it's called the story of us on YouTube i
sat down with eight couples and I
interviewed them about their love story
from start to finish in the day they met
- like the day they got married did you
learn anything doing that I mean so much
and I think all the couples that seem
genuinely happy have a really good sense
of humor about their relationship and I
think you need to kind of like keep it
light-hearted playful you know is that
what you're looking for going into your
next relationship definitely I
definitely think that the last one was
maybe a little too serious right off the
bat what did we ever see you back on
reality TV Ashley I I'd hope to like
post reality TV instead of via Qasim
Burke I'm gonna go ahead and say not a
cast member on any more graduation
[Music]
[Applause]